so
he
his kazushi patterns are front inward
front inwards
back outward
but not really it's a yid young world
so if he has a front inward he has a
front outward
and if he has a back outward he has a
back inward
so for example kotage is going to be a
front outward
is going to be a back inward
so normally we work the front inward and
equal and then go to the back outward in
coq
we're going to work
front inward
into the
this way
you're falling
nope
do you feel that in your neck
lock your body
so i do the same on my side
i lock my body
he locks his body
he locks his phone
i lock my body
he locks his body
lock your body
oh
[Music]
wait
i don't care which version
nope you have to do this
[Music]
oh
different
that's why you're having a hard time
[Music]
let's
go his body is doing the same kazushi
powder meaning it is always
a
rotating cross
that's spiraling okay so imagine like a
corkscrew
roller coaster
but there's a cross on it and it's
spinning as it's traveling on the spinal
and toward that end
his body is going to do the same thing
my arm is going to do the same thing
so i have if you
forget him for a second but i don't want
you to not do your drill
so i have an inward spiral
and then as i come around
it's over here again
[Music]
we'll do the same side
i don't do something
to try
to get him in a compromised position
i do
a inward spiral
comes around
and i do it again here
i'll do that contrast now
there you go
you see
not the same one
say same arm
same arm
so just like here
oh same arm
same arm
just like here same arm come back
rewind
grab
same arm
same one
and what you're doing here
is it should also feel the same
so i feel his weight
in his center
comes around and i'm going to feel that
same thing it's not going to get loose i
feel his whole body
when he was having difficulty moving
because my body was too heavy
whoa
don't start
doing the demenage
forget what he's doing let's feel the
drill
then you learn the actual key on okay
so i have my over spiral
well the outer spiral
so
that takes him
into the other kazushi there's the
blackout
so boom
i'm going to use that to get him back
here
now this hand doesn't go like this
boom but this hand is another
inwards flower
right over here boom hold on there
it's the same one
[Music]
boom here
because you have no pressure
do you understand
and why did it take me to tell you
you should notice that i walk towards
you because it should be threatening
do you understand
boom this hand too that's not a hand
reverse
you see it's right there
boom there here it's gonna find it there
body lock you're too far look how you're
being push push push push push me over
[Music]
inside corner
get the handle
so he has to be in a spiraling rotating
cross
that is the ritual geometry that is the
sacred geometry that cultivates my body
mind but it is also the marshall
geometry
because it's a
concentric epistemology
the
rotating spiraling cross
creates angles of cancellation which
then set up zones of sanctuary which
allows me to fight
where he can't get me
okay
so when you change your
geometry in your spiraling arms
you don't get the rotating cross so he
just standing there you see
he's just standing there you go
like he's still standing there okay
you want to capture his center
his phone said
well same thing you come back here
you just standing you're like oh he
turned
it's not enough
oh hold his body
and so we come here
his whole body is moving
his body is ready to go
but that's also what's training me
because i'm moving his whole body
he's so wide
so this arm goes
here
there is your angle cancellation
this armor is not good here so this hand
elbow is
this hand now picks it up
whoa
this hand now keeps it going you see it
this hand now is not pushing him he's
already falling
so you're not violating
yin yang you already got him going
the other way
here
this is now harmony
with where he was going
so
forget the technique
just work the potters
this one goes this way
this way into a spot before it reaches
the gate of kokuho
you should already have picked up the
other inward spiral
boom here
oh
i personally would be much more
interested in that
in a certain way okay
there was my senator my internal vectors
all that kind of thing okay
um
but
if you pay attention
as i said
this is how you get your kazushi and
your zones of sanctuary which are
necessary commercially
but another thing you get is when you
have a grappling art or a throwing art
that works through grappling
you're going to need your open-end
triangles because it is very low
percentage to grab things
when they're resisting etcetera etcetera
so you learn that doesn't work and you
learn how
to
find limbs
by first having his center which usually
people that don't understand this
inverse this and they think uh
that they're going to have a limb to get
the center but it doesn't it doesn't
work okay
so
he touches and you always have his
center right away and then you can keep
getting his center through the limb
but towards that end to work that
strategy you're going to need to
uh control the center line with traps
and that means open end triangles
because he has to land into these things
okay
so if you watch the technique now
uh you'll see that my arms are always in
front of me and they're always in these
triangle shapes okay
i was always in these triangle shapes
here
whoa
and now you've made your aikido
consistent with every other single
trapping art that's out there
as opposed to
this kind of stuff
and then you get punched in the face and
you go what happened
so everything is on my center line
[Music]
it appears to be much tighter do you see
it's not all out here like this
because my spirals are doing it all for
me
so keep your hands here
make everything work
means your hands are going to have to be
here you can't be going left to right
and you're going to be too late
you go here
when you go like this right to left
nothing
his body boom is going this way
his elbow
boom hands right here
but they're not tiny
they're just working the spirals
they're not little pterodactyl arms
hey